let's have a crack at this now I noticed
a couple of common errors just as I've
walked around the room by the way this
is the kind of question that you can see
it takes one idea and it shows you in
one fell swoop how all of the ideas that
we've been and skills or even separating
out they really are all about
understanding and studying the same for
one object right and when you put them
all together it does become a little
more hard rather than okay factorize
here's a hundred questions to factorize
and then you know find the vertex he's a
hundred quadratics and find the vertex
when you get asked to do a successive
bunch of different steps that is harder
okay so don't be too surprised if you
like mmm is it challenge it's meant to
be challenged okay let's have a go first
the factorization okay now before I'd
read the factorization a number of
you've got a factorization you've got
something looks like this something
times something okay now what I'm going
to suggest you do is before I assure you
what I'm not - dude look at your
factorization one of the great things
about factorizing is you can always know
whether you are right or not right it's
a very simple to check because if I gave
you something like okay this is not this
is not the answer
but um suppose it's more see yourself
okay it's really easy to check whether
that's correct or not whether I'm
factorized properly because to go from
this to that is one direction but
student board is too good the other way
right you still say that with a straight
face to go the other way what do we call
that - you have something with brackets
and then to do something to it and get
rid of the brackets what we call that we
call the expanding right and expecting
it he's easy we're very good at it
what's the expansion of this help me out
you'd go X and then you multiply by
these two terms so you get x squared
plus 2x right and then you've done the X
so now you do the negative one that is
going to be minus X - so you can do a
little bit of super simplifying there
which gives you this right in case um
you've never seen this metaphor before
the way I think about it is it's like
you know a pair of people coming out of
someone else's house right so this guy
he says hi
to both people right because otherwise
that's just rude like to say hi to one
person and say he'll ignore you sorry
right
the first person says hi to both and
then the second person also it says over
because they're very polite right now
clearly this is not the factorization of
this because I expended and I didn't get
back what I wanted so I want you to
check your expect your factorization see
if it expands and it gives you what you
expect
now there's my Prelude how are we going
to do this we're usually searching for a
pair of numbers right this is not Manik
because there's a two out the front so
what kind of pair of numbers what what
does my pair of numbers do what am i
searching for what do they are what did
the pair of numbers add to in this case
they add this number in the middle
negative five nine five okay what dude
the pair of numbers multiply to
something times something equals
negative 13
right yeah yeah you care with that okay
now what pair of numbers is going to do
this um 14 when you factorize it there
are only one two three four factors
further number fourteen what are the
factors you can pair them up just
thinking about puzzles don't worry about
the negative for a second I can need two
and seven and I can do what's the other
option
114 okay now which of these is gonna
give me a sum of -5 now I have to put
some signs in here it's gonna be yeah
which it's gonna be two and seven which
one's negative minus seven right so if I
go to 2 and minus 7 in there okay in
fact it's actually the numbers that you
have here cuz I made this up on the fly
so I had to make an easy
okay so it's a minus seven not
necessarily because of this right I
could have stopped these around and
still be multiplying to minus 14
so for instance I could have written
this question that leads to x squared
minus 5x plus 7 just look at that for a
second
do you see if I redid this exercise my
numbers still have to add to negative 5
do you see that and then I must still
have to multiply to negative 14 do you
see that okay
but now the numbers I want are still
gonna be 2 and negative 7 despite the
fact that I plus 7 they're right it's
because it's the product the combined
thing that I'm interested in okay so let
me get rid of that so we could do that
cells
we've got super fast negative 7 and then
2 times negative 17 works doesn't it
okay so what do I do with this pair of
numbers though because this is not like
you have to be careful with it what am I
gonna do with them what was the point of
thinking of these two numbers yeah very
good yes fantastic okay let me let me
write that down
so just thinking should you catch that
right and this is actually perfect so Y
is equal to 2x squared the whole point
of coming up with this pair of numbers
is to break apart this guy to slice it
in two so one can factorize here and the
other can factorize here please note
please notice or a lot of you doing this
when you walk around you were thinking
back in in monitor mode right so you
thought 2 negative 7
I know what to do with those numbers
I'll just write this okay
which is why I suggested to you check
your expansion it's really quick to see
that that does not expand out of this
right like for starters there's only
going to be a single x squared term
right do you see that but I need to like
in fact this this is wrong in a couple
of different ways right so different
kind of problem it's why you got to do a
different thing with these numbers let's
write it down plus 2x minus 7 X minus 7
are you happy with that just yeah it's
equivalent to the line we started with
yeah all right now what do I do
I've got 4 times instead of 3 what am I
going to do with ya
good okay once you factorize that first
pair if you've done it right you
actually don't need to really be very
much factorize in the second pair
because you should end up with the same
thing in both cases okay you have to do
that all right
now I can finish the factorization here
we go 2x minus 7
that's how many lots of it's just one
that I have okay
didn't want me to point before I move on
explain any parts okay that was part a
clubby falls out pretty quickly from
that in fact some of you might have done
Part B without even thinking which is to
solve for when y equals 0 that will give
you the roots right so you might be able
to just read those numbers off for me
where Y which is the left-hand side when
it's 0 what X values am I going to get
out of that there's an easier one in a
hard one what's the easy one to read off
minus 1 right you just look at that me
like oh that's easy
okay good one the other one you got to
work with the fraction there but you
look it's not too hard to work out yeah
it's gonna send on to because you got
2/3 because that's multiplied mattoon
right so sent on to you multiply it by
the moon 7 minus 7 gives engineers or
three and a half okay in fact I'm gonna
write that one to me
they'll be useful to us in a second